luis receives a gift card worth 25 to an
online retailer that sells digital music
and games each song costs 89 cents and
each game costs 1.99 he wants to buy at
least 15 items with this card and then
they want us to set up a system of
inequalities that represents the
scenario and then identify the range of
possible purchases
using a graph so let's see if we can do
this
so he's going to buy some amount of
games and some amount of music so let's
make those our two variables so let's
let
let's let x
equal the number
of music or the amount of music
and let's let y equal the amount of
games or the number of game units or
whatever you want to call it number of
games
so we have the first constraint here
that the gift card is worth 25
so i'll underline the gift card is worth
25 dollars so the total amount he spends
on games and musics combined can be no
more than 25 dollars so how much is he
going to spend on music well each song
costs 89 cents so he's going to spend 89
cents
times the number of songs he buys on
music plus how much he's going to spend
on games well each game
each game
is 1.99 so he's going to spend 1.99
times the number he gain number of games
he buys and that has to be less than or
equal to 25
less than or equal to 25 so that's our
first constraint and then the second
constraint is is that he wants to buy at
least 15 items with his card so the
number of songs plus the number of games
has to be at least 15. so x
plus y has to be greater than or equal
to
15. and so just like that we have our
two constraints we've set up the system
of inequalities that represent the
scenario now we need to identify the the
range of possible purchases using a
graph and this is a pretty
straightforward graph to draw this one
down here this one is a little less
straightforward because it doesn't have
nice round numbers i mean we could round
it off to say this is 1x plus 2y but
instead of doing that let's just take
out a graphing calculator and graph it
on that
and actually before i graph it let me
solve let me put it in y equals mx plus
b form or slope intercept form so the
second one right here if we subtract x
from both sides we get y is greater than
or equal to negative x plus 15. so
that's the second equation this first
equation if we subtract 0.89x from both
sides we get
199
y is equal to negative
0.89
x
plus
plus 25
plus 25
and sorry that should be less than or
equal to not equal to this is an
inequality so negative 0.89 x plus 25
and then divide both sides by 199
so you divide both sides by 199
by 199 everything is divided by 199 and
we get y
is less than or equal to well the
calculator will actually be useful for
this
we have
negative
0.89
divided by
199
is equal to
negative point four four
seven i think is pretty good negative
point four four seven
negative zero point four
seven x plus 25 divided by 1.99
so 25 divided by 1.99
is equal to
12.56 let's just go with that plus
12.56
so that that blue constraint that we
can't spend more than 25 dollars when we
put it in slope intercept it turns into
this inequality and the second
constraint that he wants to buy at least
15 items turns into this inequality so
let's graph the two inequalities or
let's graph the lines and then think
about the region of overlap
so if i have my calculator out i should
have it in a place where i could have
looked at both graphs so let me click on
graph
y equals so this first one is negative
negative x
plus 15
and then press enter the second equation
is
negative
.447
x
plus 12.56
and now we're ready to graph them so
second and then we are ready to graph
them and let's see what happens
okay so it looks like we're a little bit
out of the range of where you would
expect to be hanging out here so let me
change the range let me go into the
positive range which makes sense because
you can only buy
positive units of things to begin with
so let's make the minimum x value here
zero let's make the maximum x value here
so let's make the maximum x value here
twenty let's make the x scale let's just
make that one the minimum y value is a
zero he can he has to buy he can't buy
negative number of games let's make y
max 20 and y scale is one and now let's
graph it
now let's graph it
there you go so we're sitting in the
positive quadrant so the first graph
the first graph right here
this one on the top right here this is
the orange graph this is y is greater
than or equal to
negative x plus 15. and actually even
better so i can color it in i'm going to
pause the video real second and then try
to copy and paste this image so i can
color it in hold on one second
so i've pasted it in here so i can
actually draw on it so this first graph
here y is greater than or equal to
negative x plus 15. this is this top
line because it has a higher y-intercept
than this other guy this guy's 12.6 so
let me color it in that same color so it
is that line right there
right there you can see it has a slope
of negative one so it's that line and we
want to be greater than or equal to that
line so we want all of the values above
that line including that line we could
also be equal to that line so it's
everything above that line now this blue
line this is the other one it's this one
right here
it's that one
right over there and we have to be less
than or equal to it we can see it has a
slope less than one it's less steep or a
slope uh less negative than one it's
actually a larger number but it's it's
it's a less downward sloping and that's
because point four negative point four
four as opposed to negative one has a
lower y-intercept and we want all the
values below it or equal to that line so
all of these values over here
now the area that overlaps between these
two constraints i'll do it in this
yellow color is below the blue line
including the blue line and above the
red line including the red line so it's
this area right here
it is
that area right there
so any combination of games
any combination of games and music
that are in that area will meet both of
his constraints
and one thing you might want to consider
you since you can't buy half a game or
half a a song it would only be kind of
the integer coordinates in this region
that would satisfy his constraints so
you know whatever however many however
many games however many songs this is
and music is this would satisfy his
constraints